il y a eu une autre fuite récente sur
Tik Tok qui était particulièrement
intéressantes puisque c'est c'est un
phénomène dont on sait qu'il se produit
mais on ne sait pas nécessairement son
échelle et quel type de contenu va être
touché et il y a eu en fait une une
fille d'un document qui qui parlait de
heating c'est le terme qui est employé
par la plateforme pour
parler de contenu qui va être
artificiellement amplifié par la
plateforme pour notamment
influencer la culture de ce qui se passe
sur l'algorithme donc par exemple s'il y
a des des tendances qui vont être jugées
bénéfiques par la plateforme parce que
ça correspond à l'image qu'ils ont envie
de projeter alors on n'a pas on n'a pas
aujourd'hui de preuve que ça contient
aussi du contenu politique mais la
fonctionnalité existe et l'estimation
était de 1 à 2% d'après le document qui
a été posté en interne 1 à 2 % des vues
donc c'est quand même assez considérable
qui serait faite sur des vidéos qui ont
été manuellement amplifiées l'autre
aspect qui était inquiétant dans ces
révélations c'était que de nombreux
employés en interne avaient la
possibilité d'agir sur ce levier ce qui
peut donc aussi présupposer que ces
employés peuvent être eux-mêmes
influencés de l'extérieur et donc ça
peut être aussi un levier potentiel
d'influence par des acteurs extérieurs